la petite ville de lac-mégantic est
vraiment sous le choc un train qui
transportait du pétrole brut a déraillé
vers une heure du matin la nuit dernière
gens qui cherchent des proches sont sans
nouvelles depuis les petites heures du
matin
la compagnie propriétaire de ce train
confirme qu'il n'y avait pas de pilote à
bord lors de l'accident
deux explosions ont fameux marathon de
boston
ça se serait produit près de la ligne
d'arrivée et policiers il ya quelques
minutes nous disait que c'était une
situation en évolution c'est un
événement prestigieux c'est le plus
vieux marathon du monde
deux détenus ont pris la poudre
d'escampette grâce à deux complices
venus l'accueillir en hélicoptère cette
évasion spectaculaire soulève plusieurs
questions ici parmi les 37 arrestations
gilles vaillancourt ex maire de laval et
d'autres entrepreneurs
les accusations sont très graves je vous
mentionne que cette opération a permis
aux policiers d'intercepter 30000
conversation et téléphonique
sa victoire n'est pas une surprise mais
elle est sans équivoque justin trudeau
est devenu le nouveau chef du parti
libéral du canada
l'athlète paralympique oscar pistorius a
été formellement accusé du meurtre de sa
compagne a été retrouvée morte la nuit
dernière des accidents il en a eu
chaque fois il s'en est bien tiré c'est
finalement dans les alpes françaises
qu'il aura eu son plus grave accident il
a chuté lors d'une descente et a subi un
grave traumatisme cérébral partout dans
le monde les fans de schumi retiennent
leur souffle
nous sommes en démissionnant belvèze
aura prouvé au moins une chose c'est
qu'il est humain et à l'arrivée de la
fumée blanche la foule qui s'est rué
vers l'avant de la place saint pierre
pour être le plus près possible de la
loggia
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc le président d'afrique du sud
qui a annoncé à la télévision la mort de
nelson mandela les décédés il avait 95
ans ce tout nouvel créé une onde de choc
après les dignitaires c'est au tour des
sud-africains et de rendre un dernier
hommage à laure madiba
[Musique]
oh